today's question comes from Ethan in
Texas he says Dave I'm starting to look
at buying a vehicle to replace my
current ride which seems to have an
impending death sentence only about
$2,000 saved up towards the vehicle at
the moment if I would be putting aside
money each month that is roughly equal
to a car payment why not just buy the
car with a loan what's the benefit of
this I currently have no debt and it
just seems too convenient not to buy the
car and have it right now well that's
you know that's what most people do and
most people are broke if you stay out of
car payments the rest of your life it is
one of the key elements one of the key
data points that indicates towards
building wealth the average car payment
America today
it's 507 dollars a month over 84 months
were you to invest five hundred and
seven dollars from age 30 to age seventy
instead of screwing around with car
payments you would have from age 13 age
70 you'd have about 5.6 million dollars
I hope you like the car all the
millionaire's that we interview 90 some
odd percent of them have not had a car
payment in decades decades they said
we're never borrowing money again so if
you want to be normal
and mediocre and broke keep a car
payment your whole life it pretty well
mathematically ensures our going to be
normal and mediocre and broke it takes
your money that's what it is and so
you're thinking short term save up and
pay cash for the car
that way you'll own it you're not paying
any interest and you're not stuck you
don't get you don't get repossessed if
you lose your job in the middle
something happens you're not pinched you
own the car or you don't buy the car
Ethan you can do whatever you want to do
but that always seems easy until you
have it and then you start figuring out
it's hard oh it's not a big deal me if I
could save two dollars a month why can't
petrodollar payment just get the car now
that's what that's it but that's a very
short term
thinking mentality and the shorter-term
you think on things the shorter your
vision window is the less likely you are
to build wealth and this show is about
you know having financial peace two
words that don't go together like
airlines service think about it these
are words that don't go together and you
can make a decision on how you're gonna
live and get where you want to get